in this series I'm surprised you
understood away early the complexity and
hard craft and teach you how to cook
amazing food standing on your head that
is amazing
incredibly tender from the kitchen
novice to the budding chef I'm gonna
give you the confidence that recipes and
the insider knowledge to make you a much
better cook slice around wasting nothing
I made my name cooking some of the
world's most demanding kitchens in my
restaurants I expect perfection every
play has to be worthy of a Michelin star
and every time you may go now I will
show you some simple and accessible
recipes or fantastic food that you can
cook easily at home and Co I'll be
holding you by the hand gettin better
and better and better teaching you
everything from how to cook on a budget
to bake in real fast food and my
ultimate feast recipes this is the only
cooking course we'll ever need
welcome to my optimum cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life on right
now it's all about cooking with Chile
for me chilies are an incredible
ingredient in the cook's arsenal capable
of transforming dishes
at an excitement heat and a wonderful
taste I'm going to show you how to get
to grips with her intense flavor first
up red mullet with sweet chili sauce
cooking is about being adventurous and
having the confidence to go off piste
and being a little bit more daring so
when you start combining peanuts chili
flakes and this amazing fish red mullet
trust me you're in for an amazing treat
we're gonna make a really nice light
sweet chili sauce first off your chili
off with the top in half and those seeds
inside are very powerful incredibly hot
but full of flavor garlic two cloves of
garlic slice the garlic nice and thin so
it helps the puree the chilies in the
pesto more garlic in such a salt and
little touch of sugar in and then start
grinding
push down first
the salt and the sugar really helps the
puree the chili and the garlic fish
sauce always a base to a chili sauce two
tablespoons in a touch of rice wine
vinegar fish sauce gives it the
saltiness the vinegar gives it a nice
acidic wake up three tablespoons of
olive oil nice mix that up beautiful
look at the colors incredible now spring
onions I want the texture and the crunch
spring onions in the coriander
slice it once in fresh lime and that
goes brilliantly with a red mullet just
really wakes up the chili the garlic and
reminds the sauce that was serving with
fish and their taste
well it's delicious
look at that beautiful the longer that
chili sauce sits there the better it
gets
now for the penis and chili that's gonna
coat the top of the red mullet the
peanuts in salt in it helps the really
grind the peanuts down some people dried
chili flakes create a nice sort of warm
heat I'm using fresh chili for the sauce
but dried chili flakes for the coating
which will really crunch up when cooking
just a little bit of coriander mix the
kinder in to the peanuts and look I like
them quite textured I don't want me too
small as a powder otherwise they'll burn
but crushed lightly to coat the fish
with the chili and peanut seasoning in a
separate bowl beat two eggs along with a
splash of fish sauce
take your Philip lay in your red mullet
dip it in shake up your peanuts and then
end and make sure you push that down
cover that red mullet
not beautiful now make sure that pan is
really nice and piping on if you put the
fish in the pans cold all those
wonderful peanuts and chili just gonna
slide off the fish so we need to sear it
in and get it nice and crisp in and lay
away from you
beautiful
[Music]
if the pan starts getting a little bit
too hot
get your olive oil and just place
another teaspoon of olive oil around the
outside so it starts to heat up as it
hits the center and it really helps to
stay so much more in control and turn
nice and gently they want that nice sort
of toasted rotate crispness it adds a
really lovely flavor tilt the pan and
just baste the top of the red mullet
without really nice quickly hot olive
oil you've got that really nice roasted
crunch and I goes wouldn't leave without
soft sweetness about fish inside gas off
and just leave them sitting in there and
finish with lime and just go over each
one now
you take them out in the sauce touch on
the bottom in the turn of each fish now
to round that off serving some fragrant
rice studied broccoli amazing and there
you have a delicious peanut and crusted
red mullet with a wonderful sweet chili
sauce cooking with chiles is all about
blow your head off heat this dish uses
the exciting taste of a chili where has
a deliciously elegant and subtle flavor
as you become more confident using
chillies you'll find they can transform
your cooking chilies are a great way of
making dishes exciting and vibrant here
are three quick recipes that are full of
flavor and come with a kick
first up pasta with tomatoes and chilies
and chilies
[Music]
for the spicy sauce sliced anchovies
garlic next dried chillies great for
keeping the covers at a hit of heat on
demand
then add the anchovy oil to hot pan and
fry the chopped ingredients
add half cherry tomatoes chopped black
olives and salted capers cook to combine
the flavors
in a separate pan all drive spaghetti
another great store covered staple when
the pasta is tender but still firm drain
add to the sauce with a splash of the
water it's full of starch which gives a
great silky consistency
then season with pepper and top with
basil
packed with big bold flavors and ready
in under 20 minutes past with tomatoes
and cherry and chilies my next
deliciously different chili recipe is
grilled corn with chipotle chili butter
[Music]
first the topping chopped coriander
then add softened butter soaked Chipotle
Chili's in hot water these are dried
jalapenos which have an amazing smoky
flavor drain and chop
mixed together in season
[Music]
next fried corn-on-the-cob in olive oil
you want a really wonderful charred
flavor when colored add water to steam
through
[Music]
to eat smother the cobs in the butter
and crumble over Lancashire cheese
fantastically messy to eat grilled corn
with chipotle chili butter and utterly
delicious smoky treat my final recipe is
a chili classic jerk chicken start by
making the intense jerk marinade first
scotch bonnet chilies they may be small
but Pat real heat from a fruity punch
then chopped garlic and fresh thyme
[Music]
for spice add ground cloves cinnamon
nutmeg and allspice
season with salt pepper and combined
with olive oil next score chicken legs
so the hot spicy flavors get deep inside
the meat rub thoroughly with the jerk
mix and marinade
and olive oil to a hot dish Brown the
marinated chicken for ten minutes
then add Worcestershire sauce
cover and cook in the oven at 220
degrees for 20 minutes
hot spicy chicken easy to make and
finger licking good three different
Chili's three amazing flavors three
irresistible dishes plus next five more
my 100 tips that will make your life
easier in the kitchen first up how to
de-seed chili so you get the seeds out
hold it upright and just rub the chili
between your hands the seeds are
incredibly hot we're just releasing them
from the inside tapping it down and then
again just a final little rub now cut
the top off and then just open up and
look they come out like little miniature
Smarties and they're got the little
bottom bit off amazing next a great tip
were using spare chilies uses string tie
together the stalks then simply hang in
your kitchen in just a few weeks you'll
get your very own dried chilies great
crumbled into dishes for adding Heat on
demand chilies are surprisingly
versatile if you love them in savory
dishes my tip is to try adding them to
melted chocolate ganache but chocolate
chili truffles or sprinkled over fresh
fruit like mango or watermelon a great
tip to prevent burning sensitive skin
when working with chilies to get rid of
that spice and that heat on your fingers
a little bit of lemon squeeze a little
bit of lemon juice and that instantly
gets rid of the heat fresh lemon juice
spice up your drinks for a Mexican twist
add a dash of hot chilli sauce to fear
or using cocktails give your drink a
very different sort of King this is my
ultimate cookery course hundred recipes
to stake your life on I'll be showing
you an amazing spicy beef salad take a
little teaspoons on your dressing and
just go over but first the secret of
cooking fantastic food is to start with
great ingredients the more you know
personally about where you ingredients
are from and how they produce the better
so that we scared ask lots of questions
and when it comes to chilies there's no
one better to ask and chilli grower
Johanna plump who's been farming chilies
from mild to mind-blown for over 11
years
I eat chilies all the time every single
day she grows over 60 types on her farm
and really knows how poblanos from a
heaven arrows people think that chilies
are all about heat actually it's about
flavor as well some are sweet and some
are aromatic and they can be used in so
many different dishes when you go
shopping and you're looking for a chili
what should you be looking for what you
want to do is look at the chili and it
needs to be nice and firm and glossy
generally the bigger the chili the
martyr is going to be the smaller the
chili the hotter and if it's small and
wrinkly like this one it's going to blow
your socks off another way to tell if
the chili is hot or not it's a split it
open and smell it if it's a super hot
chili it clear your sinuses the heat of
a chili comes from an oil called
capsaicin and that is concentrated
mainly at the top of the chili where the
seeds are now when you're cooking with a
chili and you want the flavor of the
chili but not too much of the heat start
with just using the bottom of it
as you get closer to the seeds that
Chili's going to get hotter so if you
remove the seeds that also does remove
some of the heat there's thousands of
varieties out there because they cross
pollinate very very easily and that's
why the world's hottest chili is always
changing
Joanna's right with over 200 types
available all with different flavors
aromas and of course levels of heat is
important to buy what you like here are
my top Chile's whatever your desired
kick at the mild end a blow nose
these are great for stuffing have a
delicate flavor and often used in
Mexican dishes starting to get hot the
jalapeno when they're green they're like
spicy bell pepper the redder they are
the sweeter they are Birdseye where they
really start to pack a punch long thin
and pungent they're great in Thai dishes
and are often green or red and at the
top-end they have a narrow these lantern
shape demons have a delicious fruity
taste under the Firecracker of the chili
world another way to use chilies is to
smoke them and to make Chipotle what it
is it's just a mesquite smoked red
jalapeno it smells fantastic you can
almost get that like smoky bacon sort of
flavor out of it so you would use this
and anything that you would slow cook so
you're eating a chili and it's really
too hot for you the best way to get rid
of that heat is to drink some milk or a
dairy product like yogurt whatever you
do don't go for water or for beer don't
be frightened of trying new types of
chilies in your cooking experimenting
with these amazing fiery piece is a
great excuse for getting hot-headed in
the kitchen they give you a natural high
much like when you've been exercising so
your endorphins are released and you
just feel good Chili's make you happy
and they're also an aphrodisiac
Southeast Asian chefs they're bringing
they're balancing the hot spices of
chili with sweet sour and salty flavors
if you want a new twist on a favorite
dish spice it up with chili my next
recipe is super simple to make but has
wonderful depth and complexity of
flavors spicy beef salad chilies if you
use them constantly they can really add
a new dimension to the style of cooking
but the real trick is finding that
balance of flavors that really suits you
because that's the most important
so this is the most amazing sirloin you
can see it's got that wonderful marble
for me the secret behind this is cooking
it quickly season the steaks generously
salt and pepper
push that seasoning in to the sirloin
take the set on out the fridge literally
20 minutes before you wanna cook them so
it gets up to room temperature they cook
more evenly but more importantly you can
actually season right inside the steak
this little bit of fat down here season
that as well because that is what we
want to roast and get that really nice
and rendered olive oil in a tablespoon
roll that round as it starts to smoke in
with the steaks into the pan and lay
away again into the pan and lay away if
you don't hear that noise too many of
those steaks hit the pan don't put them
in so the secret now is getting that
color on the steak turning it once and
once only and cooking it for
two-and-a-half minutes each side what I
want to do is to get that bit of fat
render so it adds a lot more flavor its
hold the steak down like that and that
starts to melt the fat which makes it so
much more tender
there should be no white fat left
anywhere turn them over really important
to have that steak up to room
temperature before you start cooking it
so the inside is nice and warm so he
spends less time in the pan and more
time cooling down really important now
to fingers touch it goes in says rare
I'm happy to be rare because by the time
I let them rest then we go back to
medium-rare
team cooking outs onto a plate and let
them rest
to get my juices over
don't waste up really important next the
spicy dressing take the seeds out of a
chili to reduce the heat by rubbing it
in your hands and tapping until the
seeds fall out cut it in half and just
chop it in garlic and chili works
brilliantly a quick way of peeling it
get your knife and just slam it down
pops out very quickly in it'll touch a
salt rub start going around in circles
first you'll see it puring nice get it
off
now if we've got the heating there from
the chili and that richness from the
garlic 2 teaspoons of palm sugar this is
where it starts to have that nice sweet
sour effects fish sauce fresh lime this
is a simple fresh chili dressing and it
was something I fell in love with in
Vietnam and Cambodia because it was just
so easy give that a little mix you
dissolve the sugar quick taste mmm Wow
right vegetables a great fuss free way
to get super thin ribbons of carrot is
to use a veg peeler when they're that
thin they take a vinaigrette so much
better and radishes just slice them down
at an angle
lovely give another dimension of the
Salas music banana Charlotte they are
incredibly mellow very sweet across just
chop up the shalat and mix that through
want some sweetness in there now get
refined Tomatoes slice them in half
smart as in Sherlock radish carrots and
tomatoes next peel and slice cucumber
chopped spring onions and shred baby gem
lettuce and finally get some fresh mint
young men so you don't need to take all
those stalks off we do is hold a bunch
upside down and then take it for a
little trim and just chop that once
through you got that nice minted salad
color tablespoons of dressing don't
flood the cellar with a dressing goes
out but we can't take it away now really
mix that dressing in there make sure all
that chilli and garlic and palm sugar
wraps around the salad
beautiful on to the plate the steaks
rested it's now nice and medium-rare a
little bit of fat where you want to find
that in the salad just slice that off
that served its purpose just get that
steak nice and moist
just slice going with the grain it's
almost like slicing through butter and
look in the side beautiful pink you
slice the beef too thinly then it goes
stone-cold and more importantly all the
goodness runs out of it nice thick
slices yeah
the beef will start placing it around
you sell it take a little teaspoon on
your dressing the rest of your salad
I'll sit down on top
we'll finish it off with some toasted
peanuts peanuts in now those nuts are
really toasted nuts on get on a pan and
just crush
what they've cool down just blend them
through with a knife you can hear our
crunch they are another texture another
taste the salad and then from there
sprinkle
and then finally say that just finish it
with a little tablespoon of that sauce
and there is one tasty very well
textured spicy beef salad
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and a
hundred recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the App Store for
details go on get cooking